[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're celebrating and we're
looking back on two thousand
two thousand years two thousand episodes
of good mythical morning
now we recently surpassed um
our 2000th episode of the show and of
course
you should watch the 2000th episode
because as of the recording of this
podcast
we have yet to record that um
episode so technically we don't know if
we even made it to 2000.
that's true i mean something can go
wrong between here and now
here and then this is anticipatory but
um
i you know if it does happen maybe it'll
be emotional it'll certainly be um
special so um you know what watch that
to get the full experience of 2000
episodes by watching the 2000th episode
so we wanted to reflect on 2000 episodes
through your perspectives and also our
perspective
as well so we we put the question out on
the internet
a lot can change over 2000 episodes let
us know how you have experienced the
evolution of gmm
and how you have evolved along with it
over the years you might get a shout out
on your business more than a shout out
many
of you guys thanks for all your
responses for following us on twitter
at mythical and using hashtag ear
biscuits to
converse about episodes and to help us
know
how to talk about this stuff um
what's wrong with your phone i'm just
needing to put it on you
do not disturb i get disturbed so much
so we i don't want to you know well i
get disturbed twice as much as you
because you have glasses well i don't
understand i'm just i'm
i'm sensitive to disturbances
except when sleeping so yeah so we're
gonna
read your responses but then you know
discuss those but also kind of talk
about how we're talking about different
aspects of the way that you can kind of
contemplate the 2000 episodes and the
evolution of gmm
from your perspective and then we will
then add our perspective and how things
have changed
for us our lives our perspective on the
show
etc uh but let's look at the present
first i just want to make sure how
are you okay because i know you've been
you've been abandoned by your family
yes well before i tell you about how
i've been faring by myself i do want to
remind
you oh all the episodes
of ronstat are out right now so
a lot of people when i as i'm recording
this
you know not all the episodes are out
and and what i see is people like
man i wish i could get all the episodes
like i just finished that
fifth episode and man
i gotta wait a week well if you've
procrastinated or if you just thought
i'm just not really into scripted
podcasts i don't like the sound of that
i don't want to do that whatever your
voice is that
is when you talk about why you're not
listening to ronstat i'm sure it would
be annoying to me
what i want you to do now is i want you
to go and listen and you can
binge the whole daggum thing yeah
because if you don't like it you can
just get it over with because you do
need to listen to the whole thing
even if you don't like it uh so yes
thanks for all the positive responses
uh yes i have been alone for the weekend
um my family is out of town what was at
least three nights maybe four
it's thursday through thursday night
and yeah through and then i pick i pick
lock up from the airport today jesse and
um shepard'll still be gone for a little
bit but yes i have been a bachelor
um it doesn't make you a bachelor
you don't become eligible oh did i say
eligible bachelor or did i say bachelor
uh it's kind of redundant right why why
ever say eligible bachelor
uh because sometimes you're just a
bachelor who's not eligible i don't
that's what technically you know that's
what you are you don't know
an ineligible bachelor i don't know the
technical definition of bachelor if it
means single man
then i'm not a single man but i lived as
a single man for a weekend
and this isn't something that happens
quite a bit very often
as a married man did you try to contain
your excitement as you sent them
away well first of all they wanted me to
go with them because
we'll talk about this i guess next week
we're going to talk about our
uh respective trips back to north
carolina right because we
i mean from their perspective we just
took a three-week break
right but from our perspective we
haven't left for north carolina yet but
yet my family was already in north
carolina long story
there was an opportunity for me to go
back a little bit early and i mean
things are busy you know there's also an
opportunity for them to go and you do
not but you don't
here's the thing about it you come out
and say that yes okay cool
good uh i get the sense that you don't
feel that you have the freedom to say
that we could talk about that later but
um i was very very soft i was very clear
about when jesse asked me she was like
i'd like you to go she's like there's
not really anything on the calendar
i was like well there's always something
on my calendar baby it just doesn't
always show up
uh just meaning that i've always got
stuff i want to work on yeah
but second of all it's like i could
really use a weekend alone i'll just be
completely honest with you i could
really use a weekend on i like
being alone i'm an introvert and so i
could do that every once in a while and
just give this to me
mom um she had no problem with that she
understands
and uh so let me tell you the thing
let me start by telling you the things
that i didn't do i did not shower
didn't shower uh i got into the pool
that counts it does help some but i
didn't like soap up you don't want soap
in your pool
did when you got in the pool did you
scrub your scalp
um no well first of all i wash my hair
once a week max
uh because that is in fact you know what
the latest
the latest research is that people are
saying don't wash your hair at all
i mean get it wet condition it don't put
the shampoo in there though
really uh yeah i i'm doing that though
shampooing once a week but i didn't do
that
but what i did do is uh first of all i
got a lot of writing
done nice and there were i love to
benefit
and i was i was doing this thing where
uh
i was writing and had quite a bit to do
you know i was like i don't know what
made me think of doing this but i was
like i'm gonna work out
and write at the same time and right at
the same time not at exactly the same
time what i'm going to do is because
a lot of people say that you know
i mean i'm definitely i've never take
more than like i'm
a long workout for me is an hour right
yeah
but people who are like getting ready
for marvel rolls
and like bodybuilders they work out for
like multiple hours a day
and they take really long rest breaks
between sets because apparently that's a
good thing but practically you just
can't do that but i was like
what if i did like a really long workout
where i did like a a muscle group and
then i went and
i wrote and then i went and did another
muscle group and then i wrote
see i was picturing like a a dumbbell in
one hand and a pen in the other well
that's
that's phase two phase one is just doing
them
interspersed so i ended up
i worked out from on sunday from 9 00
a.m to 3 p.m what
what yeah i mean not crazy the total
amount of working out was probably an
hour right because it was just like
let's do some bench press and then it
was like let's go up and let's write
another
scene it was right when you were doing
the bench press were you thinking about
was the writing continuing in your brain
yeah i would go and i would work things
out in my mind and i would like to i
would talk out loud to myself
and i would be like okay but if this
happens in this and then i would go back
and i would write a scene
talk out loud stuff and then when you
were writing the scene were you grunting
as if you were still working out
no but let me just tell you i feel like
i'm on the precipice
of maybe developing a system
the workout rider that i could sell
though it would be called the
get swole uh the swole
right and we had to come up with the
tightest right
tight um get your body tight while
you're right i don't i don't know what
we gotta work on we gotta wordsmith that
but it's gonna be a program there's work
dvdx while you're right on specs
there's gonna be dvds uh
going straight to dvd just like the
thing that we're writing
um this is like a this is like a well
it's not really a
master class it's more like a uh
i don't know master class well that
would this yeah you would have to
uh that it's based on the idea that the
writing is good which is
tbd um and the workouts rendered results
yeah i think that's
i think that i think the one thing that
um doesn't require
any skill is just pushing things around
you know what i'm saying is like
you get guaranteed results if you push
things hard enough lots of technique
needed
but i also tried two
new sandwiches and i don't mean like i
went and got a recipe for a sandwich i'm
meaning that
i was like well you can eat whatever you
want you need no one else's input
so you're just gonna get new sandwiches
well the funny thing is is i had in my
mind that i was going to cook
for myself and i was going to because i
love to cook
but i but like with all the working out
and all the writing there's only so much
time in the day
so what i decided to do was get
sandwiches i'm going to try
that new burger king chicken sandwich
because they got in on the bur
on the chicken sandwich war are they
calling it something
king oh really the king the ch
apostrophe king um
and also interestingly part of their
campaign
was a little bit of a dig at chick-fil-a
because
i don't know what they they said
something like a certain portion of the
prophets from this sandwich or whatever
are gonna are going to lgbt
causes oh so they are basically just
like get a little
jab to chick-fil-a um
which i appreciate it but um
can you taste the inclusivity it's good
i'm just judging the chicken
um it's kind of gotten to the point
where and we had that mcdonald's one on
the show and everybody was like you guys
didn't have the sauce on it
yeah they didn't put much sauce on it at
the local mcdonald's that we that we
tasted it from so wasn't that great no
but you know it's
it's basically is this as big as the
popeyes is it as breaded as the popeyes
it is as crunchy as the popeyes by the
way i've given up on popeyes
you can't i just can't beat the
chick-fil-a chicken sandwich
you know um social social causes
just isolated for a second right but
here but i think the argument most
people are making is
well okay maybe they haven't made it
taste as good
that there are there are so many
alternatives now that you just don't you
don't even
there's you don't have to tempt yourself
with it
you know and i think that pies have not
had the lasting power and i have to
assume that burger king
hasn't topped it burger king got very
close to popeyes but they are kind of
just definitively a different chicken
sandwich
um more traditional like it looks like a
pop it has the same profile as a
popeye's chicken sandwich with the
breading
okay uh of a sauce pretty big on it
it's pretty big yeah pickles and you can
get the spicy one but never get the
spicy one when you're
testing the sandwich first i thought it
was good but i don't find myself
thinking i'm gonna go back and get it
what was the other place
uh well i'm talking about chicken
sandwich yeah actually i'm using the
term chicken sandwich loosely
i tried the naked chicken chalupa
from taco bell which i don't even know
how long that's been out but i saw a
commercial for it chicken
it is a taco that has chicken as the
shell
and it's not like one of the afc double
down but but a taco well the ksc doubled
down was
literally just two chicken breasts with
stuff in between them
taco bell chicken breasts doubled on
itself with stuff in the middle no this
is
take chicken put it in a machine and
make a taco show out a chicken
this isn't like a i mean what you i
don't even know what you're talking
about
you know about like taking a breast and
like folding it around stuff yeah taco
bell would never do something like that
that would so it's a flat bendable
nugget
that is is uh circular and then folded
over like a shell
no it is a it is a
nugget nugget-fied taco show
meaning that it's it was flat maybe at
one point but when it firmed up in the
fryer
it firmed up in a taco shell like it
holds its own shape sound good
like if if i were to take everything out
of it it would just literally be a taco
show
that's chicken and other binding agents
i'm
i'm thinking that can't be good it
wasn't bad
but it definitely wasn't i need to do
this again
it was like okay that's kind of
interesting and it really is
i guess it's for the low carb folk oh
but it's got fried
stuff on it so that's not low carb it's
got breading on it
gotta say i wouldn't recommend that
necessarily uh
because also just as like a safety gotta
just the kiss the the kissing
the uh chicken quesadilla yep that's set
which is which is which is that's a good
goal it's always good it's always good
um and i went to
the driving range three days in a row
okay that's good now this might not be
sound exciting to you but this is
i no you mean just standing in one place
and hitting golf balls
forever and well when you're as good at
it as i am it's fun
uh and the the uh now if you suck at
golf
golf is very frustrating but if you are
just grooving it
let me just say grooving it to
the point where people a crowd begins to
gather
no yes are you well hold on you're
telling me that you were just hitting a
golf ball off of a t
and people stopped and watched you yes
this is not it's like
pac-man final rounds like it was an
exhibition
okay now you know me i'm a big man i'm
tall i have a big arc
i'm relatively athletic and i can get
some club head speed
and what was happening is is after three
days of practice
of like hitting a bucket of balls and
kind of beating my groove back were you
like
drunk rednecks celebrating or something
like no but i did like i had my hat on
my sunglasses
all my hair coming out the back so i
kind of look like somebody maybe i'm
like a gothing personality you know what
i'm saying
like there are guys on the tour that
like have that look yeah
they're like this is the redneck golfer
yeah yeah and
um and so listen i wasn't trying to draw
a crowd
but i like step right up and watch
miguel
but what happened is is i'm i'm getting
all my
all my clubs in my bag i'm kind of
getting straightened out because i'm
really trying to get my back is
basically better and i i haven't been
golfing aggressively for a long time
because
of my back but my back is good right now
and so i'm getting my hip turned
and so i'm hitting we're at this
i'm not going to say what range it was
but it's a range where the fence which
is probably 30 or 40 feet high
is that gosh
siri i wasn't talking to you i know
you're interested in me
and why why does she speak so loudly i
don't have any idea what's going on here
siri shouldn't have said her name again
so just for those of you who who know
about this stuff
and the one percent of you who do know
about this and appreciate it
so this fence is like 250 yards out
there 30 or 40 feet
tall so to get over the fence you're
carrying it
at least 300 310 320
in the air before it hits the ground and
begins rolling
i begin hitting the ball consistently
just over the fence
and then i really didn't even build the
place big enough to contain the redneck
energy
and then i realized that a guy is behind
me
and he his buddies come up to him and
are like you ready to go he's like
and he didn't hear he didn't know i was
hearing he was like well i'm just
watching this guy drive
and you know me this is not good once i
have an audience it's like
i that's when i begin performing better
did you acknowledge
pressure did you acknowledge him you're
like you played it cool like i didn't
hear him and i'm not even
no no i was like if this man wants a
show he's going to get a show and now
his boys have showed up and now all
three of them are standing there
and then i was like well you guys want
it you're gonna get it and it was just
like
bam bam bam over the fence
and then i was like well i mean they
were into the driver let's see what they
think about the seven iron
and it was just like and then and they
were just they stayed there for that
long yeah and then the guy was like
he was i would hit it and it was like
coming off i mean i mean i was grooving
it was coming off the clubface it makes
a
great sound and he was just like damn
this is getting gross like i mean did
they put
dollar bills in your way here's the
thing if you play golf
and you know the mechanics of golf you
know how satisfying it is when it's
working and how satisfying it is to
watch
it work so i'm again i'm talking to the
one percent of you who care about this
i'm really focusing on you right dude he
like he wasn't like biting his lip was
he well i didn't make eye contact with
him i was just listening to him i never
turned around did he ever have knowledge
if he
if if if you could if he could mount one
of his balls on your tee
i think he just wanted a lesson but i
was like but i was prepared to be like
hey man
i don't teach i just demonstrate
uh anyway i'm i mean hey that's a
t-shirt i mean wear that t-shirt to uh
your top golf session i don't want to
build it up too much but it was
at least fire has a freaking has
targets to hit well i was picking
targets
that sign that sign over the fence were
you pointing
you can't do that you can't babe ruth it
out there no he would know that you were
watching you never had a conversation
you never acknowledged their
the audience no because i wanted to be
in the zone
and i was in the zone i didn't want to
be broken out of it
that's funny see i had a great weekend i
mean i get what i what i realized is
what if something would have gone wrong
like if you would have fallen
or like you would have pulled something
oh and then like they were watching you
had to
you would have acted like nothing would
have happened no i would have asked for
help
help me but i just had a a glimpse of
what you know i've been married for 20
years and what my life would have been
like if i had never gotten married it
would be no
showering lots of gold dirty bachelor
eating a lot of fast food and working
out and writing
and having basically no day or night
rhythm it was like nothing
is it's just what happens happens
it's probably not sustainable okay but
it was a hell of a weekend
wow i had the worst weekend ever why
because i ended the weekend with you uh
celebrating lily that was fine
um well that was great it was fine that
you were there no it was great
it was it was a horrible weekend because
our internet went down
which means our lives were grinded to a
halt
uh no ability to communicate at our home
because our cell phones
only work through our internet because
we have no cell service at our house
so we were cut off from society it was
like we were camping but we couldn't
even start
have fire it was bad that sucks it was
bad
you could have come to miles i had lots
of internet and uh
i mean there's a lot of room too
multiple rooms i thought about it
i mean we went to the creative house one
night just to watch something uh you
know the credo house is a good backup
for internet yeah and maybe like the
apocalypse so i'm
i'm glad you had a good time and i left
you to it
i was in misery internet-less
misery yeah i don't know how you did it
okay let's talk about uh
2000 episodes of gmm but first let's
talk about these koozies i expect i'm
telling you right now very exciting this
is super cool
i love a koozie every night when i drink
my toppo chico
i put it in a koozie okay for for
someone else
person can you give me the rationale um
is it to keep it cold or just to keep
your hands to keep it colder longer and
to keep my hand from getting cold
because if your hand gets cold
it's sucking uh cool off of the drink so
it's an insulator
it's yeah but it's not for comfort it's
for
coldness it's for coldness so your hand
doesn't get too cold but it is pretty
comfortable and your hand the heat of
your hand doesn't suck the cool we
took thermodynamics this is
thermodynamics in action and you get
this
mythicalized version of a sprite can so
every time you pick this thing up you're
like
oh look what i found is that legal what
we did with this yes
mythical.com it's a parody get yourself
a koozie
if you want it on a shirt we can make
that happen too
i love it i love a good koozie
um typically we don't put what just
we've got water bottles in them just to
demonstrate yeah that's typically a nice
i don't i don't endorse water bottles in
general
okay let's talk about gmm 2000 episodes
we're going to read through a number of
responses and instead of
going through and commenting on each one
we kind of have grouped them into a few
categories and we'll just kind of go
through and let
y'all speak and then speak to it
um let's start with ally
she said when i started watching gmm i
was barely nine
now i'm almost 17 driving i have a job
i'm going into my junior year of high
school and i've made leaps and bounds
when it comes to my mental and emotional
health
rhettlink and gmm are a huge part of
that and i am
so grateful you want to alternate hit
the next yeah
sammy fox i started watching when i was
12 or 13
with my dad in the mornings before
school
now i'm 22 about to graduate with a
degree in anthropology
and i watch gmm and gmm more every
morning my personality has
definitely been shaped by gmm i love
this
elizabeth tolbert said when my husband
and i started watching gmm we were just
dating
as freshman in college now eight years
later we're married and we watch it
every night after work jackson melvin
i've gone through puberty that's it
that's all he said
i've it was a reply to us otherwise it
would just be like a
very profound uh it's like he just
discovered it
update i've gone through puberty i've
made it
through to the other side i'm still
waiting for that to happen
to have them fully drop
i mean sometimes i'll get a zit and i'm
like is this still residual puberty no
it's not okay good bohemian maiden of
mythicality
uh said 11 years ago i was an
awkward youth watching after school and
now i'm a slightly less awkward adult
who shares gmm with my three-year-old
son
he has apraxia of speech and makes the
asl signs
r and l for rent link whenever he sees
the youtube logo on the tv
it's something magical to have created
something so enduring and stable yet
ever evolving and growing
uh which we'll talk more about later i
hope to teach my son to emulate that in
his own life
congrats on achieving it thanks bohemian
made his mythicality
lonsdale when i started watching gmm
i had short hair clean-shaven was in my
40s
and hardly anyone had ever heard of my
former job
i now have long hair long beard in my
50s
and everyone is a virologist except
me and then his next tweet was i started
watching in early february 2020.
wait what okay so basically he was in
his 40s
he was like 49 yeah and now he's in and
then he turned
50 but his you know
his his hair grew out his look totally
because he did the pandemic
uh haircut thing this is more of a
pandemic change than like an evolution
while while watching
i think i've actually seen uh richard
tweet some things about he's a good
he's uh if i'm not mistaken because he
is a
you know an actual former neurologist no
he is a
virologist oh he's not former he's just
saying basically he's not everyone's
working out
no i think it's a joke oh everyone's a
everyone thinks they're an expert on
this except for the guy who is the
expert no he said have you ever heard of
my former job oh former job you're right
okay well
yeah but everyone does think that
they're a virologist
but uh thank you richard virologist yeah
however you say it
robin tweeted i've been watching y'all
since 2015
and you raised me when no one in real
life was
i'm now 18 and just graduated living on
my own and still wake up and watch y'all
every day
uh you're also the only reason i have
twitter
oh well i guess we're the only ones
reading this assuming you don't have
anybody
following you maybe you have people
following you i don't know let's leave
that out of it robin
uh leah began watching daily in 2013
when i had two children age two and
three
in the time since then i've gotten
married adopted four
cats had another child and the oldest
who was born the same day as lando
is now heading to middle school wow
it is so crazy to to hear these
responses
of people and how much
their life circumstance changes how much
they
changed as people you know going from
being in grade school
weathering middle school to be in high
school going from
uh being in school to graduating high
school going off to college
like dating getting married i mean we're
at the top of the year we're going to
celebrate it'll be the 10 year
anniversary of good mythical morning so
we've
so we're you know we're at like nine and
a half years
right to get to 2 000 episodes
and there's it's just it's quite a
phenomenon that
you know being on the inside of it like
from our point of view
like looking out at this it's
it's so nice to hear because i just you
know
and it's nice to stop and celebrate in
this way and think about what
how much has changed how much people go
through i mean you talk about puberty
people sitting there and becoming adults
well that's the thing that's so
interesting to me and again i
very little of what we've done has has i
mean a lot has been strategic but a lot
has just been
what we thought we wanted to do right
and when it came to the show
in the direction of the show but it's
we've whenever everybody asks us like
okay well who's the show for
and we can we never have a real great
answer for that because we're like
the audience is very abroad and that
seems like a cop-out when we say well
sometimes the family will come up to us
and we don't know
who's the bigger fan the kid or the
parent and the funny thing is is
in so many of your answers and lots of
ones that we just read
there's something very cool and i'm i'm
not
taking credit for it i'm saying it's
just we kind of stumbled into it
that we created a show that you could
grow up
watching and not feel like you were
growing out of it
that you could transition from a child
to an adult you could transition from
a student to a spouse um
and still call it a part of your daily
routine
and that is it's just really cool to see
and
i mean when we started the show it was
again it was after we moved
out here to l.a you know we we had all
of our kids
but we were starting a new career and we
were like
i mean we started we did the television
show and then we kind of relaunched our
youtube career on the on the with good
mythical morning
as like a big part of that but it i mean
we we've changed a lot as well
even though we were already married and
in parents
and you know but the kids were so young
and now you know the first few episodes
the well the first few seasons we would
have all these stories about
our lives like learning to live in los
angeles
taking these kids to play dates in the
park and like the stories from
christy and jesse and everything they
were going through it's like
um we weren't we were sharing where we
were in our lives at that point
with gm and being so conversational and
then i mean a lot of the conversation
has shifted to
your biscuits but so much has changed
about us i mean look how much older i've
gotten look at this
look at this look at this gray hair you
know it was
i think the reason we were when we when
we were committed to
developing an audience on youtube at
that time
i think our instincts said we got we
have to reach a younger audience
and we had been doing that since at the
beginning of youtube we were always
older
than everybody else give or take we were
always ill guys who was
getting traction on youtube and
developing an audience so we knew we had
to reach people
younger than us and and and really
embrace that side of ourselves well and
i think there was a time
and i i don't there was a few
conversations about this
um and i think a lot of it was
precipitated
by you deciding to stop dyeing your hair
which was relatively late but so gm so
when we had conversations with people
what we noticed
especially when we had like
conversations with people who might be
considering another project or like
somebody who was in
marketing maybe brand that we were going
to work with whenever we told them how
old we were they were like what they
they always thought
we were younger that we might we were
probably in our 20s uh even when we were
in our late 30s they thought we were in
our 20s and we felt like that was an
advantage yeah we were like well okay we
got to work on youtube we got to hold on
to that
but then there was a well you know as
the relationship
developed between us and you guys and
the way that
sort of entertainment and especially you
know social media and youtuber
relationships with fans have evolved and
uh it's become much more of like a
family and there's much stronger
connection than it was than we started
we just started seeing the way people
would talk about us as
dads often uh in a
like making fun of us whether it was dad
humor or
you guys are my internet dads we were
not hiding
our age as well as maybe we thought we
had to in order to be as successful as
we were yeah and again
and it wasn't it wasn't as again i don't
want to over state right
it wasn't like oh we can't let them know
how old we are like we were we were
fine to tell you how old we were we just
thought that if you thought that we were
younger
then that was probably an advantage and
that's especially the gray hair thing
yeah yeah that was like that decision
point
i mean i think we did have this
discussion discussion but it was it was
kind of like
come on who are we kidding by that point
it's like i just i i can't
carry on with this die job and i think
it looks horrible
it didn't i didn't think it looked bad
at the time but of course it's looking
good it's very dark i just cringe
i did it myself yeah yeah like and i
would get we always did our own own hair
there was a couple of times like maybe
four times that i would i went to a
shop i went to a real trendy
silver lake stylist
and uh he he colored my hair he's gonna
tell you like huh you
you've been out here just for men and
like why uh he was
he was a soft-spoken dude very nice and
he did he didn't
you know he didn't he wasn't too
opinionated
but i had confidence like he's the guy
who gave me my
uh my new haircut oh like this is before
we met anna right uh who helps
shape our cloths now so yeah he he cut
my hair
uh it was at the place was called the
fox tail i'm pretty sure
something like that tail it's got a tail
and a fox in the title
um so he so i trusted him because he's
the one who like gave me my new
hairstyle
boy that was i mean that was a that was
a big risk because it's like i
need to get rid of this boyish hairstyle
but then when i was like you know what
i'm tired of coloring my hair myself you
can do a better job
than me then i i realized i just didn't
like
sitting there and people walking in and
out and seeing me getting my hair
colored like that was i just didn't like
that experience like that's why i wanted
to do it at home
but then yeah once once i was like i
i can't keep this up it's going to have
to change
and then we have the conversations like
who are we kidding anyway i mean it's
like
this is actually being more of
myself i need to embrace this and
it's not going to imp are people
watching because they think we're
younger than us because if they are if
we're holding on to that then that's
gonna that will go away
yeah it's like we need to we need to rip
that band-aid off well because you talk
about your hair which i mean
you know is obviously different but
definitely especially as we've gone back
uh for the mythical society and we've
done these uh
react to the early videos i don't know
what it
when it was but for a lo for the longest
time if i went back and watched
an early retin-link video i kind of was
like i basically look the same but my
hair has changed
but over the past three or four years
every time i go back i'm like man i was
a baby like
i don't know i can't face was younger i
can't tell you what has changed about my
face
i couldn't specifically point it out but
i'm like that face
is young and this face is old you know
what i'm saying it's like
it's i you begin to and i think that
we'll talk about this later as we're
gonna hear from you guys about
how your you know the show has been a
part of your life change not just in the
stage of life but it's just who you are
well so we'll talk about that personally
but like you said i think that one of
the cool things that's happened over
over time is just us embracing who we
are
so part of it is yeah i'm 43 i'm gonna
be 44
in the fall and it's that's that's who
we are we are
dads we literally were dads when we
started but we could be a lot of your
dads
and that's kind of part of it i think
yeah i definitely remember
that you know i always had this fear
that like when is this success going to
run out
and if there's anything i can control
to to prevent it from from petering out
i want to do that and
it wasn't that i thought that people
thought we were young but i didn't know
for sure
i was like if they you know this is one
of the factors if my hair goes
totally white it's like what why would
you watch that guy
it's you know just i was like i don't
know if this is good we'll find out
we'll find out yeah that's right um but
i i'm just glad that we have such a wide
range
of people watching because we stopped
just catering to a younger audience
and as we talk about the evolution
of the show we became more we came into
more of our own we came into more of
ourselves
completely and i think youtube started
to gain more
older people would watch youtube people
who were more of our contemporaries
you know would go to youtube for
different things and discover our show
and realize that
hey this can be for me if i'm
you know if i have kids if i'm older if
i'm you know if i'm retired what
if i'm a retired virologist and the
funny thing is is
now youtube as a medium
is feels kind of old like it you know
what i'm saying compared to
okay tick tock right yeah and so uh it's
funny how quickly things
i don't i mean i'm not not only
youtube's going anywhere but as a medium
it feels like this is
kind of a this is sort of a young adult
and older person's
thing now you know well let's let's talk
about the show though and how the show
has changed in your eyes um
christy scarpetta gmm's evolution from
three men she's talking about jason who
was our first editor
in your garage in your backyard three
men in a garage
that evolution to a multi-dimensional
show that still embodies the same ethos
is unique as a mythical beast i
recognize the similarities in my life
i've had to adjust develop or start over
but my core
remains unchanged gmm's adaptability
with stability
is wonderful well this is like kind of a
mission statement that we've not really
articulated but thank you and i think
it's kirsty
oh yeah sorry christy i called you
christy kirsty
um mumskin
joy i've been with you guys for six or
seven years now i've enjoyed watching
the channels
grow seeing the crew getting more
involved with the various channels and
the interactions with you guys and each
other is beautiful
you build a wonderful family here's to
another
2 000. i mean there is a sense of
the family the people that make the show
there is this family of faces
some i mean they definitely change over
time
uh in the way that families do yeah i
guess but but i think that's one of the
biggest um
that's one of the biggest
transformations of the show
in i think the reason that the show is
still going on frankly
is going from three guys in a garage
uh coming up with everything to the
amazing team that we have right now that
enables us to step in
and be a part of the show in the way
that we are now like i can just
guarantee you that the show would be
finished
if we were because we're still trying to
do it the same way yeah we kind of
shouldered that burden
never for this million years uh samantha
disner
13 i've been a fan for about a year
found you guys in a time i definitely
needed some laughter i started watching
everything from good morning chia
lincoln through to the current episodes
so i've seen the evolution happen very
quickly
it's been amazing to see how you have
grown as performers
and how the games have evolved it's yeah
that's an interesting dynamic it's like
if you're a long time
fan you you've experienced the evolution
slowly
more like we have sometimes it's harder
to see but so many people
all along the way have been gone back
and then had this accelerated
binge watching that's like it's like
i mean people make time lapses but when
you're catching up
just from last year and you're going all
the way back to chi lincoln
i mean that's i actually i think that's
what the what the next commenter
kind of fleshes out even more yeah ltn's
fridge
ltn samsung smart fridge is it what is
it
you've you've spot you've got a samsung
sponsorship in your twitter handle i
believe that this could be
uh a samsung smart fridge that has gone
sentient
oh and is now a fan okay so
we accept you we will proceed with
caution three years ago when i decided
to click on will it donut
i liked it so much that i wanted to
start from the beginning so that entire
summer
and through out half of the next school
year
i binged watched all the seasons so
i got to see how you and the show change
whether that's
waiting for link's new haircut yeah
knowing it was going to come yeah
seeing the change to the expanded format
and back
seeing rhett's hair get longer and
longer and my favorite part was waiting
for the new intros to see my progress to
catching up
overall this show changed my morning
routine for the better
i can look forward to the new gmm and gm
more episodes instead of dreading going
to school
i got the sense of being a part of
something bigger
as i became a mythical beast i was so
excited to see you live
my life was changed all because i saw a
pink donut and a thumbnail
gotta love that thumbnail uh yeah we
welcome all
all appliances right yeah into the world
of uh
mythicality appliances don't care how
old you look that's right you know what
i'm saying maybe that's the future of
the show
it's just a bunch of ai watching it yeah
that ex i mean
i that i can only liken it to when i
discover somebody
uh a musician or a band and then you
realize that they've got eight albums
you know um maybe one day
you know it's like i know that elvis is
waiting for me if i want to become a fan
one day
you know and that's it's going to be
quite an experience if i wanted to do
that
i've never done that with elvis i don't
know if i will
you're honestly the thing is you're more
familiar with elvis
than you realize you probably have heard
any song that you think
you've heard you've heard them all exact
but that's i think that's how
people who aren't mythical beasts think
about good mythical moorings oh i've
seen the thumbnails i have an
idea of what that's like you know you're
saying that we're like elvis
i like i like this and then and then um
but when you dig into it you're like oh
there's a there's a lot more here to
this experience than what i thought i
think i would find that
from elvis and especially because you
have this whole body of work and you can
you can have that time lapse experience
but elvis died on the toilet and i don't
want that to happen
to you or me while working out in
writing yeah renfrost
to wrap up this section i wasn't there
in the beginning but it has been part of
my daily routine
for years now i like how the boys have
become more comfortable with themselves
and it has allowed me to become more
comfortable with who i
am wren thanks for saying that you know
i
the show would not be going on if it
wasn't for the crew um
for the reasons that you said but
there's also this beauty that like
utilizing and platforming their talents
frees us up to be free and i think that
you know the the thing that we've
learned over the course of
entertaining is
how valuable uh being yourself
and really putting yourself out there
and uh and
an inviting connection in that way for
people to relate to you
and know that you're being real it's
something that i think we've
uh we were i think we were slower to
evolve on that
front than a lot of other successful
youtubers because we were so focused on
what it was we were creating early on
and then we made a strategic decision
with
chi lincoln and good mythical morning to
platform
our friendship and our conversations but
we
still um cordoned off
the things that we would talk about and
i think the way that we would talk about
those things
where there was a lot of areas of our
lives even though we were we shared a
lot of personal stories
that it was still very filtered and
um presented and
i mean i look at us now and the things
that we talk about here
on ear biscuits it's just like it this
is just what
i'm gonna tell you what happened you
know i'm my filter is a lot lower
you know christy still gets on me she
was like you know you don't have to
share everything with recent episodes
but
you know it's just trying to find out i
just like i enjoy the freedom
of uh being more
myself and a lot of that i think because
of your biscuits has
made its way back into good mythical
morning especially because the way
the team sets up the episodes where
we don't have to we don't have to plan
something to deliver
or to produce or engineer results
so we're more in a reaction mode in a
being ourselves mode and not a producer
mode because when you try to get into
that producer mode and
you're thinking about the way this is
being presented you're just not as
engaged
you're not as funny and that's not as
fun to watch but yeah i think that
i mean we talked a lot about this when
we got ready to tell our deconstruction
stories right
when we uh there was this massive
part of ourselves that we had kept from
you that we sort of once we opened that
up it was
it was such a massive part of who we
were and i think it kind of
relates to the way that we presented
ourselves right you go back to the
beginning of the show
so that 2012 um you know
we were one year into being in la
really like six months in into being in
la
from a spiritual standpoint where i was
at at that point was
i basically had a full-on crisis of
faith
right um but i was still
think i was still calling myself a
christian and still kind of believing
that there was
something in the sort of broken
down pieces of my faith that i could
assemble into something i was still
going to church still call myself
christian that kind of thing
still had certain beliefs about jesus
and
but a lot it was super shaky but i in in
you can speak to where you were at but
you're pretty similar you were going to
church as well
yeah i i would say i was in a very
similar place yeah
it wasn't the type of place that you
wanted to process that publicly
right you know especially having never
processed any of it publicly before then
it was like and also the last point the
internet was a very
very different place 10 years ago
meaning that there's very few people who
were talking
that openly about what they thought
about everything it's like now everybody
tells you what they think about
everything and you're almost expected to
say what you think about everything
very different time but we kind of
opened up this
personal window into like our stories
and our friendship
but we were still in this kind of
uh the default is to make this family
friendly like now the interesting thing
because we talked about this we and and
i think what we've said in the past is
we're like
the show evolved in terms of its rating
in terms of its fam
family friendliness and it's over the
years it's gotten less
family-friendly whatever that particular
term means to you
uh and i think that the thing that we've
said in the past is
this is related to the fact that our
kids have our kids have been growing up
with the show and so our standards have
changed
i i think i don't remember but i would
venture to guess that i was the one that
articulated it this way because i felt
like it i felt like we needed an
explanation and i felt like for me at
least
this was a true but still partial
explanation that i gave at the time
which was
you know i like to as my kids get older
i think i think there's a parallel with
the sh with the show
aging up along with our kids because i
think about like
i want them to be able to watch it and
it be the type of thing that i'm
comfortable with the things that i'm
i'm saying and the things that we're
doing and the the angles we're taking
the jokes we're making that
uh i can watch it with my family and as
my family gets older
then those that those standards um
start to loosen mm-hmm um
it's not that i described it that way
and i left it at that and it's not that
it isn't true
i mean for me it's not really true
because
i've always let my kids kind of watch
whatever they wanted to watch
even from a pretty young age and so they
were they were already experiencing and
watching things that
definitely went beyond the line that gmm
even goes across
today when they were younger so there
was an incongruity there for me
but and also one of the things we i
don't think we've ever
shared this but like you know even when
we were christians even when we were
like
neck deep in evangelicalism our
personal unfiltered conversation with
each other was
i say 90 to 95 identical to what it is
now in terms of how much we curse
yeah like we we cur like we've cursed
our entire lives there wasn't a moment
there wasn't a time in which in my
private life with my best friends and
with my wife where i didn't curse
right and even in front of my kids quite
a bit like that's just how
i have always talked and i never thought
that cursing was some like sign of
faith but we had just this idea i was a
little more conservative than you but
but yeah it was the type of thing that
in in so that evolution
it wasn't like whenever we our our
beliefs started to change
that we got more loose-lipped we cursed
more no it's like and also with innuendo
which i think
we still don't curse on gmm and the
reason we don't
curse on gmm is because if you do curse
you
even if you curse and bleep it you
automatically get put into a different
category on
the platform and you don't get served to
as many people so you don't
get you know you don't get as many views
and our business doesn't work the same
so we're going to continue to be family
friendly
but when it comes to the innuendo the
jokes that go over the kid's head we've
always been
super innuendo heavy and are just
conversations with each other
personally personally absolutely yeah
yeah i think what what you're seeing on
gmm
now is how we would always
joke amongst the you know
yeah just privately amongst friends but
now
i mean like ren was saying we're more
comfortable being ourselves
on camera yeah and so that's you know a
more honest reaction
might sometimes elicit uh a [ __ ]
that then i think they had to cut around
a few times because like we're
we're actually so comfortable behind the
desk
and not just in good mythical more but
especially in good mythical more
that we're just we're reflecting who
we've always been in that way yeah so
it's not an
it but it is so it's just an evolution
of how we're presenting ourselves
that it's more of a opening the door to
who we really are
more than it is to changing and the
funny thing is when you see it from the
outside and also you kind of know our
story
like you think there's a correlation
these guys left the faith and they've
got
and they've gotten more and more crass
it's like well i've kind of always been
crass it's just
now i'm just don't think that it matters
that you know that but
what i will say just in case you're
getting like are you
are you guys gonna keep pushing things
like i feel like
where we've gotten on good mythical
morning is a it's honestly it's about as
far as you can go before you begin
getting categorized differently
and so i think that we we have no desire
to go any further i think that there's
the right amount of innuendo
on on the on good mythical morning a
good mythical more
but i you know maybe there's an
opportunity
in other venues for that and uh that's
intriguing
but um yeah for for gmm
i think we're i mean we dance a little
bit around this line and like
sometimes we're still pulling back we're
not just pushing pushing pushing
there's some we're pulling back from
some things
it's like you know what oh yeah some
some jokes just end up being distasteful
we're not trying to provoke
like okay that butt chugging joke thing
was like okay if i had to do that over i
wouldn't do that again
because it was okay we can pull back but
we're open to trying things because
it's it's more we're just comfortable
being more of ourselves
and sometimes pushing and that might
mean that some people are less
comfortable
with letting like coming in at this
current season and
letting their kids watch with them but
our desire is that for
most people who kind of are you know let
their kids watch like pg-13 movies or
whatever
you're gonna be able to let your kids
watch like we don't we're not trying to
make gmm an adult show gmm
is it is a family show but when i say
family show what i mean
is that no matter what part of the
family you are
the child the parent the grandparent
there's something that you can connect
with you can enjoy it
yeah and if you were to be offended
you're too young to be offended
right or you're or you're getting a
little bit of an education
right that's our realizing something you
need to you need to figure out but i
i mean the i think the biggest evolution
is just because of ear biscuits it's
kind of had this
retroactive impact on the show and also
realizing that that's
it resonates with people you know and i
think
as we get into
more user comments uh
that becomes clear so a generally
distanced rennie mae
at loudspeaker i found gmm in the few
months following the breakup of my first
serious relationship i was conf
it was a confusing time because a lot of
who i perceived myself to be
stemmed from who my ex was so when we
parted
it felt like i wasn't allowed to be
myself anymore
gmm was the first thing i really enjoyed
that was
my own it taught me that it was okay to
be weird
and that i was allowed to like whatever
the heck i wanted to like
that that being myself was absolutely
fine
it led me to find other things and
people that i really enjoyed
further to that seeing gmm go through
its many formats
taught me that it's fine to try and fail
so long as you're moving towards
something better these days i'm happier
and by no means perfect
but i like to think i'm constantly
moving towards something better
thank you for that that was a three
tweeter
um from mythical peach
i started watching in 2018 i was on
disability leave because my anxiety had
worsened
i was so depressed my daughter suggested
i watch gmm to give me something to
smile at
it worked i immersed myself in all
things mythical and life started to have
color
fast forward three years and i'm at a
fabulous job
doing wonderfully watching every
mythical thing i can get my hands on
i credit rhett and link with turning my
life around by showing me
daily the funny weird uniqueness that is
them
love you guys well listen i appreciate
the compliment but i'm not going to take
that credit
we're going to give that credit to you
for the
the uh the changes that you've made in
your life but we are
glad that gmm was a part of it and that
we were along for the ride
yeah that's that's that's awesome
v robin said i first subscribed when i
was 16 or 17 years old and this month i
turned
23 in that time i've gone from hating
myself
realizing i wasn't straight and gender
binary
sad all the time with no clue from my
future to
a job i love knowing i'm a non-binary
lesbian
loving myself and working out
understanding my mental health issues
and helping them
overall being happier and better
the darkest times were when i was 18 or
19
at uni when i had insomnia anxiety and
possible depression with no effort to
even watch youtube
i refound gmm last year and it's my
daily positivity dose
v slash robin yes thank you
joe minnesota joe that is
i am more honest about who i am now
especially in the last 18 months
in the deconstruction episodes i no
longer feel like i
failed my family or am i bad person just
because i didn't fit their definition
of good in good times and bad i have
looked to
the gmm family to share in celebration
and in mourning
i lost my best friend this year to covet
and felt so alone
the daily episodes kept me going through
those first few weeks
it was my version of putting one foot in
front of the other
joe thanks for sharing that i'm sorry
for your loss of your best friend
and uh yeah it's just
i mean we we get a lot of messages we
hear from a lot of fans
and you know over the years especially
when we were touring too but
to to know that what we make
is is such an integral part of people
moving forward with their lives whenever
they encounter um
resistance or um uh
hardship or bottom out for one reason or
another uh
never could have imagined uh just a
couple more and then we'll unpack some
of this
em emma bowl 93
i've learned to be more confident in
myself as we have all grown to love each
other and you guys in this community
i found it really impactful that
self-love was a prominent feature
i've learned that what i wear how i act
and what i do
is an integral part of my personality
and it's very encouraging for me when
expression in all senses of the word is
included in an episode of gmm
and hey just yourself be if weird is you
and that's pretty cool
thank you emma and finally nina nifik
over the years gmm helped me through a
breakup then college
then surgery graduation changing
friendships
therapy and self-acceptance as the
mythical experience moved forward
i grew stronger wiser and happier and
gmm connected me
to the mythical hive mind
got a little creepy there at the end
again that's that refrigerator talking
no but this is you know i think we
when we started this we we said that
thing the very beginning the very first
episode
you know we want you to we want this to
be something for you we want this to be
a part of your daily routine
part of that was just good marketing you
know it was just like
we want you to see this in this way
because when you because we're going to
keep giving it to you we're going to
give it to you
the same time every day so many
decisions that we made again
they were made because we just kind of
figured
it seems like something that's not
happening on youtube
is a reliable show like people are
getting content
some people are doing it daily but you
don't know when it's going to upload you
have to go to their twitter to see
them say oh 17 more minutes and it's
going to be we were like
reliable can we make something that is
dependent in the same way that you can
tune into a television show that you
like
so let's upload this thing at 6 00 a.m
eastern standard time
every single day without exception
unless there's some crazy technical
problem
it's only happened a few times out of
2000 episodes right let's talk to
the audience as an individual for the
most part right we're talking to you
we're uh a certain distance from the
camera like we made a very conscious
choice to be like
this camera i ca i don't know what the i
think we use like a
we use a lens that is that kind of
approximates a human field of view now
we haven't really talked about this
before
and it wasn't um super intentional but
it was it was something that was kind of
behind our intentions and sort of a gut
instinct
that we want this to feel like you're
sitting across from two
people now when you watch a typical
television show when you watch a
newscast
if you've ever been in a studio where
they're making a television show and
this was the case when we
shot online nation we're like why is the
camera so
far away like why is the camera
30 to 40 feet away sometimes on online
nation well that's because i mean for
the newscaster thing
you know how would you meet the
newscasters at the at the state fair
i mean i'd wait in line and meet greg
fischel the meteorologist i'd wait an
hour to meet that guy
multiple years in a row and then you get
up there and you're like i
am i'm close enough to shake his hand
and that's too close to a meteorologist
right that's too close to uh to an
anchor
but we were like you know it's like i
don't want you speaking the news
at my face right at a point where i feel
like i could smell your breath
but the framing and all that was very
intentional but again
it wasn't this strategy where it was
just like this is gonna get people to
connect with this show in a way that
they're going to and
you know 20 seasons from now gonna write
about it in this
way that the the show has been with them
through these transitions we never
none of that was intentional we never
knew that that committal money would be
a
life resource for people and that it
would be
a source of of of comfort and if i
if you were to go back in time to the
2012 version of rhett and link again
you got to contextualize this with where
we were at spiritually which is
very much still believing that there was
a lot of hope
for us kind of you know re-constructing
our christian worldview and still seeing
ourselves
for lack of a better word is like an
ambassador for jesus right
i didn't know how it was going to happen
and i didn't know what i believed
but i still had this hope that i was
like i'm still
in this position i'm been given this
platform
and again we never like talked about
spiritual things in like an evangelical
way like trying to change people's minds
about
their their faith but it was but we
still saw ourselves as like
maybe being in the traditional christian
understanding a light
right in that way in a very particular
way right like standing up for
jesus and god's word and that kind of
thing and
if he honestly if you were to read some
of these comments
and people are like if you would have
traveled back in time and read us those
comments when we started goodman
you guys helped me with my transition uh
and
now i you know i'm comfortable with the
fact that i'm not straight and that kind
of thing
we would have been like what what is
going to happen like what is this what
is this show going to become are we
like is this show going to become like
the modern day version of sally jesse
raphael or something like that like
dr phil and his brother phil yeah i
would not have known how to predict what
the show would become
hearing people talk about it in this way
uh
obviously you might you know what you
could have sent us emails like these
emails are from the future and it could
have just been like
you know you helped me figure out who my
real father is like
you helped me resolve my paternity
issues i didn't even realize that maury
no this is just our show became moral
it's like that
it could he could have gone that way
apparently like that's how drastic
things have developed and if you had a
said no the reality is is that you're
still let me show you an episode from
the year 2021
and you would see like again you like
communicating the fact that you were
literally ingesting ramen noodles up
your butthole
um so that's bringing good into the
world
how is this edifying people's lives and
it's i don't think that particular
segment did as you know we ditched
earlier it didn't we
that won't happen again right yeah sorry
about that but yeah it's like we
we didn't we didn't calculate it we
couldn't have anticipated it but we
we've experienced personally the freedom
of being
more of ourselves um and and
sharing that honestly and not presenting
a packaged version of ourselves
now we still do that even even here
on the podcast i mean we still there's
things we don't
share a lot of times because they're not
our stories to share
or there's certain aspects of things but
we're
we're so much more free and it's been so
much more rewarding
to us personally and
but still it wasn't calculated that oh
this is going to resonate with people
like i'm actually
i so many people said i
you know i figured out my sexual
identity and i had the confidence to
come out of the closet or to you know
that type of thing that's to have that
impact on
on people's lives is just is flooring
but even when people say you know what i
just
i learned to embrace my weirdness it
is in that person's life that's an
equally powerful statement you know
coming from somebody who is weird
and it's we harness all of this for
comedy and for
for entertainment value on the show so
it's easy to forget
that like it it is a true expression and
it does make a difference so
i'm really encouraged for all the people
who said you know i'm
if if someone has a problem with me
being weird that's their problem
you know and that's that's the message
that we send just because
we're comfortable connecting with each
other and
uh there's no real judgment there
or very little judgment between the two
of us right it's it's mostly a
celebration
and if we're not celebrating what the
other guy does we're celebrating the
fact that we can turn it into comedy
which is kind of the same thing
right i mean i feel like
i am still i'm growing more comfortable
with the fact that this is how people
see the show yeah um
i'll admit that this continues to be it
continues to be a struggle for me
um i think that
for a couple of reasons i mean one there
is just this in the same way that
any normal person who did something
who that wasn't necessarily designed or
intended to
help someone and then you hear that it
did help them
it's there's just a human sort of like
embarrassment about that
you know what i'm saying like i think
that most people are just a little bit
like
oh man i didn't i didn't mean to help
you in that way
and so i you the fact that you're giving
me credit in this way makes me feel
uncomfortable
um but then i think there's a for me
there's a second
part of it which is um
a lot of this kind of goes back to the
core of my personality the way that i
think about things and the way that i
think about entertainment and
many of the reasons that i got into the
entertainment business because
i'm a performer you know i'm i'm trying
to create
things that sort of give me a sense of
self-worth
we're not going to go back into the
enneagram episode if you want to listen
to it if you haven't you should but
just the idea that i'm much more
comfortable
with people connecting with things that
i sort of
do as a performance right like it's like
okay well we have a
song we have a music video we have a
sketch and you
enjoyed that creation the achievement
the achievement uh but when you start
talking about how no the thing that
you're actually connecting with is
me as a person with you as a person with
the two of us and our friendship and
you're kind of
moving beyond the performance and the
things that we're trying to put out
there and the things that are very
designed and curated and you're actually
bypassing that not that you don't enjoy
the stuff that we create
but that you're actually having a more
thorough and deeper connection with us
as people that feels like something i
can't control
you know what i'm saying it feels like
something that i can't manufacture it
feels like something i can't go into a
room
and conceptualize something it's just
like no you're just
you're actually just connecting with us
as we connect with each other
um and that's just something i am
continuing to grow more comfortable with
as more and more people articulate it
but i'll be honest with you that it's
not
a natural thing for me to be okay with
that it's kind of akin to accepting
unconditional love i mean it's i don't
know that it's
i think well at a certain point in a
relationship
yeah there there is this unconditional
love
that you know someone you're bonded to
would have and sometimes that's
maybe difficult to uh
to accept you know i think it it has
been nice to
know that like the more that i just
embrace my weaknesses and call them
uniquenesses so to speak
it's like i oh i discovered that i'm
accepted
for and celebrated for
for being myself you know it's like okay
so a casual viewer may think i'm just an
idiot
but a committed mythical beast
will celebrate it's like you know what
he i want to
i want to be more like that in the sense
that i might not want to make
say that exactly what he said or do
exactly what he did but the spirit
behind it is something that people
celebrate
and it is a freedom that it's like oh
these mythical beasts know enough about
me
that like i feel safer being myself even
though i know that there's a risk that
something might come out
sideways because i know that i've got
i'm under
i'm understood more so for me it feels
like uh
it actually feels more safe oh i
definitely i definitely
feel way safer
and way more comfortable than i did 10
years ago
i think the the point i'm making is that
there's still this
in in there there's a weirdness to it
not in the weirdness that you were just
talking about but like
there's this thing where even it's
something as simple as
um again we don't know whether or not we
don't know how emotional we're going to
get in the 2000s episode because we
haven't recorded it yet but we have
obviously demonstrated that both of us
have the capacity to be emotional
on the internet and um
if you think about like okay like when
we recorded the the the episode where i
got emotional the most recent one
talking about jesse right
and it's like there's a weirdness to
and maybe this is something okay i'll
just be honest with you when i have seen
other youtubers cry yeah some are more
known for crying than others
i've always had this aversion to it
because
i interpreted it through the lens of
performance i'm not saying it wasn't
authentic
but like you know what it was on a video
that was being monetized
that had ads on it right and so and
that's the case with us like
we get paid it's kind of a squirrely way
for getting
we get paid by the advertisers uh on ear
biscuits and that's how we're able to
make
the show and make it a part of our
business right and then the more
we are ourselves and the more
comfortable we are and the more it's
like well
i'm crying right now not because i want
you to see me cry but because i want to
cry
there still is this weird thing that
when you are yeah
a performer when you're on camera and
now you're in do you think about the
most successful
episode i'm i mean i'm talking about
your biscuits now but just as a way to
illustrate this
the most successful episode of your
biscuits by a long shot is the episode
about ben where we both got
really really emotional talking about
him and so then if you're
only listening to the smart fridge out
there who's telling you
how you should react to the reaction of
the audience the smart fridge would say
you need to cry more talk about ben
moore
you will get more views and more money
you know what i'm saying yeah
it becomes this that's i'm not i don't
know how well i'm articulating this but
what i'm just basically saying that
the more real we get the more ourselves
that we
are and the more that people respond to
it it gets very
weird for me because i see what we do
still in a performance context because
the more people watch the more money we
get and the better our business is do
you know what i'm saying
so those are just things that i haven't
quite reconciled i'm not saying i want
to not be vulnerable and i don't want to
be honest
it's just weird when you put yourself
out there and you are accepted
and then you're like well i can actually
benefit quite a bit from being accepted
yeah i'm taking a risk yeah but not
really because if i'm vulnerable
in 2021 it's actually seen as a cool
thing to be vulnerable
we've yeah we've crossed that that
threshold
and now we're experiencing that so now
we're knowing what we're having to learn
what what the what the parameters for
personal health and are
and what the what the experiencing that
tension and
people say you're so brave you're so
brave for saying that i'm like
right it's like i guess it can be a
manipulation
right so it's yeah so that is the
you know that that's the trap we don't
want to fall into yeah it's like you
want to be
you want to be honest but you don't want
you don't want to be
dishonest with your honesty like if i do
a tweet sometimes i'll do a tweet thread
that's
especially serious about something that
i'm passionate about
yeah and then 95 and the reason i'm
doing it
honestly the reason i'm doing it is
because i hope that there's a
rhett out there me from the past
and i'm trying to talk to that red right
i'm saying hey man go ahead come on over
because
these things you're holding on to it's
not where the life's at man
that's that's the process that's what
i'm trying to do yeah but then
a lot of our fans who are the ones who
follow me on twitter respond
in a this is brave you know i'm
i thank you for saying this like and i'm
not saying it doesn't help them but like
it makes me uncomfortable
because i feel like i'm being rewarded
for my vulnerability when i'm literally
just trying to say something that will
get somebody to think a little bit
differently
right does it make sense yeah so gmm now
first of all this is much more prevalent
on your biscuits
um but i think what you were getting at
earlier is that
all of this thing that's happening all
the stuff that's happening across all
the mythical properties that might be
most concentrated in your biscuits
it's spilling over into the way that we
approach good mythical morning and the
comfort level that we have when we're
on camera we may be doing something
really really stupid and we're not going
to suddenly make good mythical morning
into something where we're talking about
political or religious things because
we're trying to give you a break
from all the [ __ ] and all the
conversation to just have a laugh
but we are being more our selves
in that place i don't know i mean and we
know we we've got
we're getting better at turning like
giving ourselves over to that and that
is a it's a that's a
performance technique to say with
cameras here
with crew in the room with plans being
made and producers expectations
and our own expectations we're learning
to
just go into a flow an artistic
flow and and it's so there's it's still
a performance
but it's a but it's a personal one and
and uh i'm encouraged that
more and more people are noticing and
that the show is evolving in that way
that it you know as much as we seem to
be dependent on food to get people to
click
on the show it's like click for the food
stay for the friendship
is like what we started joking about
because it's like
there's still a core that
in in that comment earlier i think it
was kirsty's comment about how we're
you know we've changed so much but we're
still
they're still we're still who we are
yeah so much of us is still the same and
our
our relationship is still the same in
the in the right ways that like
you keep coming back to that and and
i'm just glad that people see it because
we didn't
we didn't know that's what we were
presenting and we didn't know this we
were creating this environment yeah and
that that we were inviting this
community to be
built around the things that are being
made mythical
um and i'm just
you know the people that are becoming
mythical beasts
are you know they're they're great
people
you know they're people who actually
they what they
they like us too it's not they're not
great because they like us but it's um
it's it's nice to have people notice
those things about you
and to just to to celebrate
who we are and welcome us giving
more of ourselves uh through the things
that we want to create and put out there
and and i want to take a second to
to also say that um
you know every internet creator has
whatever you want to call it a fandom
you know that hat
is is characterized in a certain way
right and there are certain
there are certain fandoms that are toxic
right
uh the really cool thing about the the
vast majority of the mythical beasts
um at least as far as i've observed it
and especially
as i've observed it through the lens of
other people so like you know
i noticed science mike said this months
ago
maybe years ago but the first couple of
times he came on gmm
and the thing he said to us is the first
thing he said was he says your staff
is absolutely amazing i
absolutely love coming to mythical and
working with your team
because they and he's got experience
going to other places and he was just
like they are so accommodating
so friendly so nice and they've got
their [ __ ] together and i appreciate
that
the second thing he said was your
fans are so nice
and encouraging and he's like you know
because a lot of
mythical beasts have kind of migrated
into to become fans of science mike and
so you can see it through somebody who's
an online personality
who's fielding these comments and these
observations from people
to just feel that encouragement i think
sometimes
i just kind of take it for granted i
mean i know i just talked about how if i
do a tweet thread that's supposed to be
thought-provoking i'm uncomfortable when
people say thanks for being brave or
being vulnerable i'm not saying don't
say that i'm just saying i'm
that's for me to reconcile but i don't
want that to communicate that i don't
appreciate
how encouraging
and frankly just loving our community is
right
it's uh i don't think that that is a
characteristic of all
internet fandoms no if we have the best
fans
yeah i mean we i mean we have the best
community of fans there may be some that
match it but
i don't think there's any that's that
surpass it
you know and um i think we wanted
we if you would ask us what kind of
community we would have wanted to build
like when we were just getting started
it would be like
the most comedically critical people
that still like us
because right they will think that we
are the funniest thing ever
yeah the fact is we're not the funniest
guys ever we're not
i really wanted to be but i'm just
slowly realizing that i'm not
because we're not the funniest but we're
funny and we're other things too that
people
uh people relate to we're we're a lot
more
just like normal humans who aren't
always the funniest but there are other
things too when it matters
yeah i'm not going to say that our fans
have just noticed that in us but i think
they've inspired that
in us too because we start to we it's a
relationship that we've started to
understand
that there's an opportunity for us to be
the best versions of ourselves
as we continue to tell people to be
their mythical best
so we continue to evolve so many things
have things
changed drastically since the beginning
of good mythical morning
and it's so it's not the stances we've
taken
as much as it's the honesty
in the evolution that we've experienced
um as individuals as friends
and also as a community yeah
and i'm so i'm so grateful it turned out
this way and not how we thought we
wanted it to go
oh yeah even though it's still a
struggle to think that sometimes when
you think about
like a particular project we want to
make or
put out into the world but um i still
want to be
i'm not ever going to let go of it
either because it's pathological or
whatever i'm never going to stop
trying to make the best possible thing i
can make but i am very
grateful that we have a community
that isn't just concerned with us being
excellent
right and um and and what that might
mean sometimes you create something
that's actually not as good as everyone
says that it is
um and there's the the the three inside
me wants you to be
just tell me how it is just give me the
facts man but you know what
this is probably a better way to live
but i i mean
i'm tremendously grateful and i think
this exercise
it just just makes me so glad that that
things
are going the way that they're going and
that the community
uh of mythical beasts are who they are
and um i just you know 2 000 episodes
of any show is quite a feat how many is
judge judy done do we know well yeah
let's
don't bring her into this because that
that'll blow us out of the water yeah
thank you for being here whenever you
got onto the boat
even if i know a lot of people got onto
the boat you got off the boat and you're
back on the boat
uh come and go i get it i'm the same way
uh
but thank you for for being here at any
point
that you have been a part of this thing
and the way that you contribute
say it all the time and we mean it that
we wouldn't do this without you we
couldn't do this without you
and you make what we do
incredibly fulfilling yeah
here's to that man now give us a wreck
because it's your turn
oh yes okay so as we come out of the
pandemic and we begin to party
once again if you're gonna invite people
over to your home to party first of all
play music not you personally oh
like if you if you got a gathering of
people at your home
and you're not there's not a soundtrack
you've missed a
giant piece of the puzzle so first of
all rectify that that's my first wreck
the second wreck is without thinking
you need to play a particular band
called krung bin okay i'm gonna spell
this if i can remember
you can have to help me khr
u u a n b i n u h there's a g
in there so just remember the k h
r to begin u a
g b i n chromebin it's a tie word i i
didn't know this
it's a trio from uh
texas don't let that throw you off
because it does not sound like texas
music
they actually resist being categorized
because what i would have multiple
cultures like this just like
funk it's just just this groove they're
always in this very intoxicating
groove and every single song they've
ever made without exception
is something that you should have
playing during a party did i introduce
you to them or did you
introduce me to them because i i
definitely found them independently of
you i don't know if you
i don't know if i introduced them to you
but i found them independently
like they came up on a spotify yeah it
started getting pushed and then i was
like
and every time i heard it i was like man
who's this old band
who's this 70s is that that was what i
thought like the first time i heard that
was like oh this must be an old school
band
no they're making music now a lot of
instrumental stuff but then
uh they're getting into more uh uh
vocals too and they're doing something
album with leon bridges
um the paul mccartney album that just
came out they got
they got a song on that and it it sounds
like a krungman song
and it just has a little bit of paul
mccartney vocal it doesn't sound the
other way oh yeah
yeah well i did it the right way and
then you know it for my party for my
for my my hangout party like that's all
we listen to we put that playlist on
yeah i kept asking you i was like is
this still them because
yeah i i would just do like crung ben
radio until it'll keep coming back and
then it'll start mixing other bands in
you only them but it was only them yeah
and i was like how many songs can you
have that are just
amazing krongman all right hashtag ear
biscuits next week we're going to get
into
the longest trips back home that each of
us have taken
since moving out to los angeles 10 years
ago
three weeks in north carolina we'll
catch you on the flip side of that
hashtag your biscuits let's celebrate
2000.
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best